[Music]
did you wake up feeling a little groggy
this morning I know I did that's normal
considering millions of Americans lost
an hour of sleep it was time to spring
forward to Daylight Saving Time Victoria
Saha spoke with a doctor on how losing
that hour of sleep could affect your
health
as we get ready to welcome in Spring we
can say hello to darker mornings and
lighter evenings but it comes at a cost
there's definitely evidence there are
higher risks of of heart attacks and
strokes all in that week following the
transition Dr Gregory Schneider with
Roseman Medical Group says that's
because of the one hour of sleep we lose
when Spring Daylight Saving starts a
seven year study published by the
National Library of Medicine says there
were a significant amount of patients
admitted for afib during the week
followed by Spring Daylight savings
women in particular saw a higher
increase this our shift is particularly
disruptive because it it changes our
whole exposure to light during the day
but there are ways you can help your
body adjust so as you spend Sunday
evening getting ready for the work week
make sure you get as much sunlight as
you can before going to bed and as many
students are on spring break this week
Dr Schneider suggests keeping their
sleep schedule as normal as possible
don't have to get up at six but try not
to make it noon Victoria Saha 8 news now
now from an economical standpoint
studies show businesses benefit from the
time change as it's still light out by
the time many are off work they tend to
go out and shop and dine